a new documentary highlights the
struggle that families often endure when
a loved one is in prison
about 2.3 million people are
incarcerated in this country
the documentary is called time it comes
out today from amazon studios
it focuses on the richardson family it
chronicles matriarch
fox rich and her fight to keep her
family together
while her husband serves a 60-year
prison sentence for armed robbery
tarika duncan shows us their push for
second chances
they were a young couple in love high
school sweethearts who after 10 years
together
said i do sybil richardson who goes by
fox rich and her husband robert
had big dreams rob and i had a dream to
open
shreveport's first hip hop clothing
store
afraid of failure and desperate for cash
they robbed a credit union in 1997.
we had entered into a world
that we would never forget
the documentary time explores that world
[Music]
judge's office showing the emotional
impact incarceration
can have on families
[Music]
with the help of old home videos we see
the richardson family grow
as fox ridge endlessly calls for a
second chance
the richardson family is waiting on a
ruling determined to free her husband
all in the name of keeping the couple's
family and their six sons
together they have absolutely no idea
what it means to have a father in their
house what fathers even do
we see her trying to maneuver the
bureaucracy of the system
director garrett bradley what do you
want people to see
when they watch this documentary that
people really start to
question this the role of forgiveness
in our society as a way to move forward
can you take me back
to 1997. the thinking in a in a word
would have to be desperation
and when people find themselves
desperate uh they do some of the
craziest uh
craziest of things robert was armed the
day of the robbery
he never fired any shots in 1999 he was
initially sentenced to 60 years in
prison without parole
fox rich who drove her husband and
nephew to the bank
served three and a half years behind
bars what do you say to those people who
will look at this story and go well they
you know robbed a credit union you
commit a crime
you serve the time i would just like for
them to experience
a day of incarceration in america and
what it looks like
we all make mistakes and come short
maybe we at one point in our lives did a
a
bad thing but that doesn't mean that
we're bad people
what do you think needs to change within
the criminal justice system
most states have clemency um available
through their governors
all we need is our governors to pick up
their pen and
every year find one percent of their
prison population
who deserves to go home and home
finally came in 2018 louisiana governor
john bel edwards granted robert
richardson clemency
time was lost but this couple's love for
one another
never left it really feels like
a love story do you see it that way very
much so
i believe that uh love has gotten us
through as a people has gotten us
through a smorgasbord of our difficult
times
and uh mass incarceration is no
different at the end of the day
um miss duncan love is the most divine
chemical in the universe
and it dissolves everything that is not
of itself
the richardsons have six sons as you
heard they range in age from 14 to 27.
the couple started
a non-profit foundation to help other
families like them navigate
the prison system and say they're still
working to get their nephew out of
prison ontario smith
who they say is serving a 45 year
sentence you know you guys this film
was a work of art beautifully shot and
such a dynamic couple
that we were able to interview i can
tell that i'm looking about their sons
too jericho one is going to graduate
from dental school next year
another son is going to harvard law
school 2021
for better or worse that's what your
marriage i'll say thank you very much